we played for you in the angle president
biden claimed it was neanderthal
thinking
for texas to end the mass mandates two
months ago
so let's see how they measure up versus
a state that kept those strict mass
mandates in place
now texas has 29 million people or so
reported just 388 new covet infections
and zero deaths yesterday meanwhile new
york
has about two 20 million people had
1085 new covet cases
and 39 deaths of course governor cuomo
of new york has been handsomely rewarded
though for his gross mismanagement
according to these new disclosures the
love gov raked in
5 million bucks for his book on
leadership i love that
not bad for a total fraud here with me
now is lee zeldin new york congressman
and candidate for governor
wow congressman how big of an issue is
this going to be the cover decisions
in your race big time over five million
dollars
are you kidding me last time i got an
update about a month ago
he had sold about 45 000 copies of of
this book so
that rough math seems like it's over a
hundred dollars a copy you could go buy
it for 15
a copy right now on amazon i don't think
that you'll be doing that at the end of
the show
neither will i uh but you know the
nursing home order and cover-up
uh you're talking about the loss of life
you're profiting off of
really i mean this is blood money
profiting off of uh the suffering
physically
emotionally financially of your
constituents
of new yorkers what he should have done
this time last year was
show remorse publicly apologize for the
mistake of his order
be transparent with the public he said
he was too busy to provide that
transparency
but he wasn't too busy to go after this
multi-million dollar
self-congratulatory book deal so has new
yorkers outraged
it's the ultimate hypocrisy and governor
cuomo made an announcement today on
masks watch
effective this wednesday we're going to
adopt the cdc's new guidance
and regulations on masks and social
distancing
for vaccinated people you will still
need to wear a mask
on public transportation the subways the
buses nursing homes
homeless shelters correctional
facilities schools
congressman are new yorkers ready to
ditch the masks
yeah i hear from new yorkers all across
the state especially all these new
yorkers who have been vaccinated
and then they see the cdc guidance come
out several days ago
and andrew cuomo is still saying that he
wasn't going to loosen up
the mask restrictions here in new york
so you have a whole lot of people
scratching their head
and what it comes down to is the
governor's ego he wants to be the one to
give you your freedoms back
you have new yorkers looking at places
like florida and governor ron desantis
where your money goes further people
feel safer they're living life freer
and they're they're leaving and those
who are staying saying why can't we have
it here
this governor's ego is getting away of a
whole lot of different decisions
restricting individual liberty
impacting the operations of businesses
where they haven't survived
and freedoms and privacy in so many
respects this governor has been
infringing upon it
and that's why you're hearing from not
just republicans but democrats too
they want to save their state they've
had enough they say cuomo's got to go
yeah you've got to pull over those
disaffected democrats who are seeing
their state hollow out to places like
of course florida and other places
congressmen will be following it thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else